this is teacher Jail
yeah yeah bet I can guess what some of
these guys did right now I'm taking you
off my team and handing you over to the
coach he's gonna take it from here all
right here's the rules Kemosabe number
one every day you're here you've got to
sign in
sorry it's waiting for number two okay
[Music]
what you're working on uh trying to come
up with ideas for a new book philosophy
but not quite sure where to begin Plato
says all philosophy begins in wonder you
know Plato I dabble
Jack Phillip homemade shortbread yes Wow
hmm what are you here for ray for this I
tickled some of the other teachers no
why what can I say I'm a tickler I love
to make people laugh but I don't know
any jokes hmm
it only takes one person though to call
you a teacher tickler true or not you're
ruined you are ruined but it was true
very much yeah so have you got so far in
this book oh I don't know something
about the distortion of the ego that
comes from late capitalism's denial of
death mind if I type this down I mean it
may help to have someone else tickle the
keyboard yeah I'd like that
but this desire for a so-called answer
reflects a society obsessed with the
ephemeral ephemeral ephemeral yes yes
Phillip yes I'll tell you now that I
have a clear thesis this book
practically will write itself I mean I
think we can have a draft in a month I
do yeah can we talk yeah one sec look
this thing is getting blown way out of
proportion it's Jack you know you're in
the wrong okay how about how about a
one-day suspension I don't know I think
this this policy really needs to be
examined I mean these kids are old
enough to get pregnant they can't be
alone for two seconds that's literally
the reason they shouldn't be left alone
look it's one day okay how about a a
slap on the wrist we'll put the whole
thing behind us Jack my fingers are
getting cold
ah you know what I gotta go I'm so sorry
Ralph I don't like this any more than
you do
[Music]
you